and this one is good it was sent by
media galore days or even and if you
were judged in a trial by combat who
would be your champion
well does it doesn't have to be someone
from Game of Thrones because you know if
it doesn't have to be someone from Game
of Thrones I might pick one of my
wildcard characters like Lohengrin my my
wildcard German night two can conjure up
a a suit of absolutely invincible ghost
steel armor and then go steel sword that
can cut through anything by an act of
will that's his superpower so he would
make mincemeat of any one of the seven
kingdoms even even malaria and steel
can't stand up the Lohengrin smote those
steel okay but if it had to be someone
from the Seven Kingdoms boy that's a
tough one and also the question are they
alive or dead I mean can I pick if I
could pick Sir Arthur day in the sort of
the morning he's a pretty formidable
warrior but he's dead before the books
begin Jaime would be a good choice but
only if he has both hands so the next
one deep over every suspect Joffrey
Rossella
and common we're not he's no Robert was
not a real intellectual giant he had
many grievances against Cersei but that
never would have gone on him I think
partly because he if he ever had known
he would have killed everybody and he
never would have dreamed that anyone
would be so stupid enough to risk his
wrath and his wrath could be
considerable okay oh this one is lots of
fun this was sent by a Mina Kelly
cacophonous earth Magus and the question
is what did Patrick Kane do so the
prostitutes didn't charge him again yeah
so what did Podrick Payne do so the
prostitutes did not charge him guys you
know I read these books and there's this
TV show that's done by David Benioff and
Dan Weiss and some of you may have seen
it sometimes they put things in the TV
show they're not in the books so you're
gonna have to ask them what Podrick
Payne did because that saying is not in
the books and I know nothing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this one was sent by Alex of Kara how
would you describe the relationship
between Brienne and Jaime I don't know I
wouldn't would you describe it I mean
that's an interesting question it's
evolving I mean it began as very
antagonistic but they're getting to know
each other my microphone is falling
apart here and I still be can i still be
heard I hope so with a little rubbery
thing back so you'll have to continue to
read the books to see where that ends up
okay he's a very very very big fan of
your books for her joy was her ever
writes the chapter tougher se caen is
clearly the darkest nerd
in all the series how long did you wait
to reveal all this mystic horror
Lovecraft and part of the story in
consequence we are all rising the great
banners
yeah that is a dark chapter but there
are a lot of dark chapters right now in
the book that I'm writing you know it is
called the winds of winter and I've been
telling you for 20 years that winter was
coming and winter is the time when
things die and you know cold and ice and
darkness fills the world so this is not
going to be the happy feel-good book
that people may be maybe hoping for and
some of the characters in red dark
places of course that's that's what you
want to do I mean you I'm not writing a
series in the traditional sense I'm
writing one really long really long
novel with multiple points of view and
in any in any story the classic
structure is things get worse before
they get better so things are getting
worse for a lot of people